Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome back to Bad Dream:Coma.
Now we're going into the graveyard which, if
you remember from the original series,
is the first place we ever came from. The
very first, so we're kind of going back.
Hello!
I'd--! Ah, Goddammit! Oh no!! What, do the flowers hate me?!
I just got back! Wait... that didn't ruin an
ending, I still got the available endings.
So maybe I'm okay.
Ooo, oh I remember- Uh do I remember
that? Am I crazy or am I- is that familiar?
Is that what it used to look like? Is that what it
originally was way back in that day? Oh coo-kee cool!
It's all so cool. So I'm going to
assume that the nasty plants are just
something I shouldn't go near and
they're just bad and they bit me,
not necessarily that I did anything bad.
Ooo a bloody flower?
Okay, that doesn't seem good. Ooo, bone?
Good! Oh spidor! Spidor want a bone? Go fetch!
Go fetch it off that cliff! Go off that
cliff huh? Spidey boo! Alright fine then.
God, the music is so...ooo! Visceral; I love it.
Hello, anybody here? Can I just look at
you real close, can I touch you? ...That's weird.
Ooh hi. What the hell- what are you!?
Can I chop you off? Euugh
I don't like the way that's undulating! I don't often get to
use the word "undulating" but I think it's
only appropriate. Okay, there's another
one.
Why are you earth worm bastards
undulating around here? *Eerie noise* Okay I think
that's my answer and my cue to leave,
ooh.. that's blood. Maybe. Who knows, honestly.
Okay so- oh, God,
Where'd that blood come from?
And what was that that just ran by the back of my
head? *Getting louder* Why's there so many people
screaming around here? I don't like it.
I do not like this.
Hello? Knock knock? *Another eerie noise* Alrighty then.
Whoa! What did I get?
I got matches. They're slightly bloody but
I got 'em. Ok, what does that mean?
Can I burn this- oh, I can't burn that, okay.
But I got ma- Hi earthworm, how are you doing?
*Screeching noise*
Well that's a new one, but okay, alright. But that did
something, so now I have matches... Don't know
what that means, don't know why the
splotch of blood is there but okay- *Interrupted by eerie SFX* ...ok
Oh, hi, I didn't even know you were here.
Oh, I can light this candle. Oh, once again-
Ohhh, why there's a key, okay. Once again,
I just didn't have all the pieces of the puzzle.
I didn't know there was even another way
to go- *Yet another noise* are you crying or are you crying
blood? I mean I guess you're
doing both if you're crying, but- are you
crying blood, more importantly? This is what I w- Ahh, I didn't mean to do that.
*Rapid chipping of stone as Mark grimaces* I'm sorry! Sorry I kept doing it after I did it.
Where is it- Oh! Hi. Is this key to here?
No.
Key is to the other one. We're making progress here!
Alright, so I'm gonna- wait
there's another- *quiet high-pitched squeal or scream of some sort*
*Eerie-ness intensifies as Mark starts rapidfire clicking*
*Spooky still intensifying* *Tensely* Sorry-
*Mark continues clicking around*
I don't know what the screaming is!
*Loud rumble* Thaaat is not good!
You want a flower there? There you go! How's that?
Oh, you love it, oh it's great... Ok..
Hi. Were you screaming? Lady?
"What are you doing here my child? Have you come here
"in search of the source of our problem?
That's a fool's errand... Death left this
"place a long time ago. We're not able to
get away from this dream without death.
"You see...we have to 'die' here in order to
get back to the real world.
"Sadly, Death has not visited anyone for a
long time. Even those who were hunted down
"by the scary monsters. Funny... That
immortality would cause people to summer- suffer.
Weird... "Nothing but us is real here. This
whole world is built of our imaginations."
How do I know YOU're real?
"Unfortunately,  it gets worse every moment... People are
"scared of their own shadows so their
minds make up new monsters. The dream is
"turning into an even worse nightmare. It's a vicious circle." *Scream* "You don't have to
"worry about me, my child. Compared to the
others I can take care of myself.
"I've been here for a long time and I've
learnt some tricks." ...Like what?
"If you still want to keep searching, you should
check out the crypt. You may find some
"clues there. But the door is locked with
some kind of special lock. I have no idea
"how to open it. Look for the clues in the
crypt." Okay will do.
Thanks lady, you're so nice. Nice cankles.
Okay, you carry on, I'll be... I'll be back
maybe. I dunno. Can I open this with a pickaxe-
no, okay. Alright.
I'm gonna try to- okay, I gotta open some
sort of crypt here...how about this key? *click* Yes!
Okay, hello! *That eerie noise*
I auto-saved so something bad might
happen, but I also- I could have picked
the flower with the GLOOOVE!
That would have been smart! But it didn't give me a
bad end so I guess it's okay. I don't
know what else is here. Anybody in the
coffin? Anybody using it? Hello? Shovel?
I've got one already but, you know, I just
thought I'd get another... So I got a glove now.
Can I glove that guy? Can I pickaxe that
guy? There's gotta be somebody that glove here.
I got- *Odd wheezing sound* ...The frick was that?
Oh- hi! Also, hello rat. You want to be
burnt alive? You wanna get shoveled?
You wanna get boned? Pick- something? Can I do
nothing to you?
*Chomp* Ow!!
Okay...
Alright, fine then.
So you're guarding that... There's...something
else... Gotta be something I can do to try
to entice that rat away from there. *Screech* Right?
*Smash*
Whoa! I didn't even think about that!
Why did I need to do that?
Why did I need to break that? Is this open now?
*Eerie noise returns*
Why did I need to
break that, there's nothing down there. Shovel?
*Gasp*
Ah, why am I digging into this grave..?
Hello, sir, are you not dead? Or are you-
oh you're not dead.
Hi, hello, welcome to the party.
Ah.   Mind if I take this hand?
You're- you- you seeing this hand? A-thank you
kind sir!
Oh thank you. Get back in the ground now,
get back in the ground. Get back in there.
Alright, would you like a nice tasty hand?
No? Can I leave this on the box or
something? Why do I have a hand?
Why- you- would you like a hand!?
*Chomp*
Oh, gross! *Eerie noise back at it again*
What was the point of that? Can I burn
you now? Can I do somethin'... No, you're gonna be
occupied, how about I come back. Oh!
Spider poop? Rotten meat.
I could have just pulled it off myself...
Hey, would you like some rotten meat, n-yeah alright I'll take the skull now.
*A wail of disgust*
Would you like a skull in return? No? Alright fine then.
So this skull... *eerie noise* Something's gotta be done about
this skull. Maybe the skull goes as- ahh. ...Ah.
But not all the way there.
Bone? *click* Ah! I need another bone.
Ahhhh. I gets it,
I gots it, I goots it!
All right.
Sir, can I have another bone? Hey, you got bones to
spare, come on man. Stop being so stiiiiingy.
*Erie noise* Oh maybe when the spider's done eating!
Can I have this? Thank you!
You take care now, you take care. Alright,
you take care now. Alright bye, alright bye.
*Click* There you go. I'm in! Hell yeah.
The Grim Reaper? Can I light this candle?
Shoop-di!
*Sound of grating stone* Ooo... Hi there.
Ooh. "Ars Bene Moriendi" ...I don't
know that means, and I don't think I
pronounced it correctly, but okay.
Ahh.
Okay.
That's nice.
It's dark now.
Why is it dark now?
*Click, click* What did that do?
*Click*
*Click* Hm?
*Click* What did this do?
*Knock knock* Oh!
It's night now- OHH! I need to collect the
STARS! That's beautiful!
Oh, that's beautiful! "Hmm..." Wait what-
"Try to end the night somehow."
What- fuck, I-
"Find a way to end the night."
I didn't even read what you said!
...Not in this world-
"Waiting is not enough in this world." Oh. *ding*
So I know what I need to do, it's obvious. *Chuckle*
I've been looking at the stars all my life. I think I'm gonna stop- ooh hi buddy, I forgot you there.
Also, who put these candles here? 'Cause I certainly did not.
Okay, there's gotta be... there's a star there-
but that was only four.
There's gotta be another star that I missed somehow.
I'm gonna take this interface away.
Yee, yeet.
Or maybe a star that's not necessarily in the sky.
Maybe there's a star somewhere else...
You know what I mean? You know what I'm saying- in the picture!
Ooh! Wait, no!
Back, back, back, back!
Where do I go!?
Back, back, back, back, back, back!
In this picture, there was a STAR!
I remembered.
That's why that picture's there.
That's why.
And now all the stars are there. A sweet little
pentagram!
Mmmm, that's a hole I don't want to stick my hand in.
*Grating stone*
OH, GOOD!
*Smacking* Hello...No-No thank you!
I'm busy in here.
Privacy please! You stay out.
*Sudden darkness*
Hi!?
*Continuous whispers in the background*
Hello?
*More whispering*
I DON'T WANT ANY!
*Faint clicks and still more whispering*
*Thud*
Okay! ..Alright GOODBYE! *Match flicks*
I think! Oh my GOD.
What did it take!?
Hey, that was mine!
You dick...
Oh you d- oh you dick, it's locked now?
Lady,
"You've met her, haven't you?" WHO!?
"She was here!
The hiding place must have hidden
something very important!
"Something so precious that it brought Death here."
Oh my God... what does that mean?
Oh, it took the skull. It took the sk- Oh.
Oh- what the hell happ- "Don't-"
What is that!?
"Don't follow-"What is THAT!?
It just erased it?
As if reality doesn't matter, it just erased it.
.."Please" what?
"Erase me?"
Uh.
"End my torment?"
"Wake me up?"
"From this nightmare?"
*click*
"Thank you."
What the hell?
What the hell.
Oh- Haaaaa...
"Good evening." G-Good evening?
Good evening, how you be? How you been, how's the family?
"Please don't be scared.
"Awful things are going on out there, but
it's nice and safe here. I see you have
"matches with you. Don't play with them
here. They're very dangerous! You can burn
"yourself or cause a fire! Better give them
back to your mom or dad. Anyway do you
"have parents? I don't, but my friend us-used to have them. He asked me to watch
"over them. They're sleeping dug deep in
the ground. There's not too much work with
"them, but it'd be easier if I could have
my own body. Someone stole it and now I'm
"left alone with this." Oh. "It wasn't very
nice. Can you help me look for my little body?
"I can go with you. It'll be fun. I just have
to detach myself from this silly body..."
"Can I borrow your scissors for a moment?"
*Snap snap*
"Thank you so much. Can you leave me alone?
Come back in a moment."
Okayy. That's weird.
Oh. Too soon, too soon?
Alright, I'll see you in a bit.
Okay. Alright. Cool. Alright, cool.
Hoooo, Nelly! Alright.
What about this lady?
"Have you found part of an eraser? This is it! Death
has erased people from this world with it.
"If we could just find the other parts...
You have achieved a lot. Please, keep on searching!"
Alright, fine. I'll see if he's
done chopping his head off from his body.
You-you done? You need to be alone? Okay, alright,
well, see you then. Oh! This is open! Okay, I
didn't know this was open. Oh, all right
then.
*Ding* Hello. Okay, I let the bug out, that's nice.
Okay, got a jar that's nice. There's a
heart, here, huh that's- *creak*
OHHHHHHHhHHHHhhhHHHHHhhhh
Hi.
How're you doin'?
You good?
You all right?
You okay there?
Is there any reason for me to be here? Looking at that up close, I guess not.
So was there no
reason for that? OH. Hi.
*Teddy bear squeak*
That's horrifying!
*Squish*
Ooh, that's real weird.
That is really weird.
*Splash*
OHHHHH
That's we- horrifying!
I painted a doooor with the blooood and that woooooorked...somehow.
*Nervous laughter*
Yaayy, spiders like meeee, greaaat.
*Inhale*
Nasty plaaaants, greaat, didn't mean do to that one,
but that is what it is.
So anyway, that's the end of chapter three.
Oh my God this game is awesome. I love it.
Oh it's such a good point-and-click puzzle!
AHH, it's so deep! I love it anyway.
So thank you everybody so much for watching
I will continue on with this. I don't
know where we're going next, I think the
*Outro music beginning to play*
forest, it said, but it's getting really
cool, so let me know you thought down in the
comments below. Thank you everybody so
much for watching, and as always
I will see YOU in the next video.
Buh-bye!
*Outro music playing*